I want to show you a way that at least I
find more useful to subtract numbers in
my head and I do it this way not it's
not necessarily faster on paper but it
allows you to remember what you're doing
because if you start borrowing and stuff
it becomes very hard to remember what's
actually going on so let's try out a
couple of problems let's have nine
thousand four hundred and fifty six
minus seven thousand five hundred and
eighty nine so the way I do this in my
head I say the nine thousand four
hundred and fifty six minus seven
thousand five hundred eighty nine you
have to remember the two numbers so the
first thing I do is I say well it's just
what's nine thousand four hundred and
fifty six minus just seven thousand
right that's pretty easy because I just
take nine thousand minus seven thousand
so what I can do is I'll cross out this
and I'll subtract seven thousand from it
and I'm going to get two thousand four
hundred and fifty-six so in my head I
tell myself that nine thousand four
hundred and fifty six minus seven
thousand five hundred eighty nine is the
same thing as if I just subtract out the
seven thousand as two thousand four
hundred and fifty-six
minus 589 right I took the seven
thousand out of the picture I
essentially subtracted it from both of
these numbers now if I want to do two
thousand five for two thousand four and
fifty six minus five hundred eighty nine
what I do is I subtract five hundred
from both of these numbers so if I
subtract five hundred from this bottom
number this five will go away and if I
subtract five hundred from this top
number what happens
what's two thousand four hundred fifty
six minus five hundred or an even easier
way to think about it what's 24 minus
five
well it's nineteen so it's going to be
1919 hundred and fifty-six let me scroll
up a little bit so it's 1956 so my
original problem has now been reduced to
1956 minus 89 now I can subtract 80 from
both that number and that number so if I
subtract 80 from this bottom number the
eight it disappears right 89 minus 80s
just nine and I subtract 80 from this
top number I can just think of what's
195 minus eight well 195 mind
eight let's see 15 minus 8 is 17 so 195
minus 8 is going to be 187 and then you
still have the 6 there so essentially I
said 1956 minus 80 is 1876 and now my
problem has been reduced to 1876 minus 9
and then we can do that in our head
what's 76 minus 9 that's what 67 so our
final answer is 1867 and as you can see
this isn't necessarily faster than the
way we've done it in other videos but
the reason why I like it is it at any
stage I just have to remember two
numbers I have to remember my new top
number and my new bottom number my new
bottom number is always just some of the
leftover digits of the original bottom
number so that's how I like to do things
in my head now just to make sure that we
got the right answer maybe to compare
and contrast a little bit let's do it
the traditional way nine thousand four
hundred and fifty six minus seven
thousand five hundred and eighty nine so
the standard way of doing it I like to
do all my borrowing before I do any of
my subtraction so that I can stay in my
borrowing mode or you can think of it as
regrouping so I look at all of my
numbers on top and see are they all
larger than the numbers on the bottom
and I started here at the right six is
definitely not larger than nine so I
have to borrow so I'll borrow ten or
I'll borrow one from the tens place
which ends up being 10 so the six
becomes a 16 and then the five becomes a
four then I go to the tens place for
needs to be larger than eight so let me
borrow one from the hundreds place so
then that four becomes a 14 right or 14
tens because we're in the tens place and
then this four becomes a three now these
two columns or places look good but
right here I have a three which is less
than a five not cool so to borrow again
that three becomes a 13 and then that
nine becomes an eight and now I'm ready
to subtract so you get 16 minus 9 is 7
14 minus 8 is 6
13 minus 5 is 8 8 minus 7 is 1 and lucky
for us we got the right answer and now
you know I want to make it very clear
there's no better way to do this the
this way is actually kind of longer and
takes up more space on your paper than
this way was but this for me is very
hard to remember it's very hard for me
to keep track of what I borrowed and
what another number is and etc etc but
here at any point in time I just have to
remember two numbers and the two numbers
get simpler every step that I go through
this process so this is why I think that
this is a little bit easier in my head
but this might be depending on the
context easier on paper but at least
here you doesn't have to borrow or
regroup well hopefully find that a
little bit useful